[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna challenge Captain Jack Sparrow
to a game of quiz up in Pirates of
Caribbean category and ready yep what
question does Jack Sparrow ask the King
of England in Pirates of the Caribbean
on Stranger Tides have I threatened you
before no you got it right then how many
bounty hunters did dark later hire to
find the Millennium Falcon see you
five four three or six
three wrong in this five six what type
of music is Dazzler known for sold disco
rock or jazz let's go which character
steals back the Black Pearl in Pirates
of the Caribbean on Stranger Tides
I'm gonna guess these kids you got it
right again
Kent Nelson was which hero Specter dr.
fate Phantom Stranger or dr. midnight
Campanella
I had no idea might be a dentist as a
dr. fate in this duck fate what color is
a Flying Dutchman green red blue or
white
it's pretty sure enough cheering alright
how many sets of binders did Han Solo
have on him while prisoner in Quad City
none three one or two
I'm gonna guess two
- is right the Silver Surfer used to
work as which supervillains Herald
Galactus the Joker Lex Luthor a doctor
[Music]
- and always have Sun on your back and
wind in your sails heavy